[Applaudissements]
amis téléspectateurs bonjour vous êtes
sur le plateau dès maintenant l'émission
qui revient toujours avec plaisir et
toujours avec vous sur l'actualité
politique de la semaine hashtag et
maintenant si vous souhaitez réagir
aujourd'hui autour de moi un casting de
très haute volée ils sont à l'aise en
fond de court mais ce qui les aiment par
dessus tout c'est monté au filet ils
n'ont pas peur du débat avec moi
aujourd'hui un smasher Philippe manières
bonjour bonjour vous êtes cofondateur et
président de vice solides vous êtes
l'auteur du livre le pangolin est l'ISF
comment le monde d'après nous rend tous
fou c'est aux éditions de l'Observatoire
bonjour Virginie Riva ça va vous êtes
journaliste politique chez contexte
merci d'être là Christophe agiton
bonjour sociologue militant état de
mondialiste je renvoie votre livre pour
la justice climatique stratégie en
mouvement c'est aux éditions les liens
qui libèrent et Juliette Medel est aussi
avec nous aujourd'hui bonjour ancienne
ministre votre dernier livre est à
retrouver aux éditions de l'Observatoire
il s'intitule un impérieux besoin d'agir
dans cette émission il y aura des
paillettes puisqu'on caméra à Cannes se
demander si les artistes crachent dans
la soupe on cherchera à savoir ce qu'il
se passe dans la cuisine politique
espagnole ou des élections anticipées
ont été convoquées on se penchera sur le
plan du gouvernement pour lutter contre
la fraude sociale et sur ses plans pour
lutter contre le rassemblement national
merci président Larcher mais d'abord
revoilà la réforme des retraites et la
certitude mais avril sans vote du
Parlement mais un petit groupe d'une
vingtaine de députés résistent encore et
toujours à une loi qu'ils estiment
antidémocratique les élus centristes
liotes ont donc déposé un texte pour
l'abroger mais avant son éventuel examen
la semaine prochaine le camp
présidentiel tente de le torpiller il
estime que l'initiative viole la
Constitution il est même parvenu
mercredi à supprimer sa principale
mesure en commission bon c'est peut-être
plus simple en images regardez
le gouvernement laissera-t-il
l'Assemblée nationale se prononcer sur
cette proposition de loi ou aura-t-il de
nouveau recours à des dispositions
visant à en empêcher le vote comment
monsieur de Courson allez-vous c'est 15
milliards il y a une chose de sûr il a
mis une seule réalité c'est que vous ne
pourrez plus jamais monsieur le député
venir dans cette émission et doctement
faire la leçon sur les finances
publiques ce texte vous le savez
monsieur le Président est
anticonstitutionnel et personne n'est
dupe de la manœuvre qui se joue la
réalité c'est que lorsque le résultat
d'un vote déplaît à la nupasse elle n'a
qu'une réponse l'obstruction madame la
Première ministre d'abord l'obstruction
c'est vous tordre les règles ce n'est
pas appliqué les règles madame le
Premier ministre vous pouvez entrer dans
l'histoire en ouvrant une page nouvelle
de notre république parlementaire vous
auriez entrerez hélas comme une
Fossoyeuse de la démocratie française on
va mettre les pieds dans le plat avec
cette question le gouvernement a-t-il
peur du débat une question de position
très tranchée sur ce plateau c'est un
duel au sommet d'un côté Philippe de
l'autre Christophe Philippe vous avez 45
secondes vous allez nous dire pourquoi
selon vous non le gouvernement il n'a
pas peur du débat alors c'est pas qu'il
a pas peur du débat je pense qu'il a
peur du débat au sens où il ne souhaite
pas se tiennent sa ressorti à l'évidence
ce que je dis et je pense qu'il n'a pas
tort d'avoir peur du débat en tout cas
de ne pas souhaiter qu'il se joue de
nouveau pourquoi parce que d'abord à mon
avis il a vraiment eu lieu ce débat
contrairement à ce qu'on raconte aux
enfants c'est vraiment vraiment faux que
il y a pas une loi qui a été votée c'est
vraiment vraiment faux que cette loi si
elle a été votée aurait été votée dans
des conditions qui sont pas
respectueuses de la démocratie la
Constitution a été respectée et je ne
vois vraiment pas pourquoi deux mois
après on reviendrait sur ce texte par
ailleurs quand vous demandez aux gens
s'ils sont d'accord pour travailler plus
ou pas vous avez vu ce que donne les
sondages la réponse est non il y a
absolument aucun bénéfice politique pour
le gouvernement à faire cette réforme il
le fait en responsabilité et Dieu sait
que je suis pas d'accord avec ce
gouvernement sur beaucoup de choses mais
faire cette réforme est nécessaire il a
le courage de la faire et je vois pas
pourquoi il se permettrait enfin il
s'offrirait un deuxième débat pour
ouvrir à nouveau cette question qui est
impopulaire mais mais c'est une deuxième
débat le premier débat en fait n'a pas
vraiment eu lieu quand on regarde les
arguments qui ont été utilisés on s'est
aperçu qu'ils ont fluctué tout le temps
on nous a dit au tout début c'était
Emmanuel Macron et ses ce qu'on faisait
cette réforme pour trouver des crédits
supplémentaires pour lutter contre le
changement climatique ou payer les
hôpitaux ensuite ils ont changé de ligne
ils ont expliqué qu'il y avait un énorme
trou et puis ensuite ils ont continué à
changer de ligne en disant que c'était
une réforme juste et que les bénéfices
de cette loi permettraient d'apporter
par exemple une retraite minimale à 1200
€ par personne et par mois après pour
s'en dédire parce qu'on s'est rendu
compte que ça ne concernait que quelques
dizaines de milliers de personnes donc
depuis le début il patauge dans le débat
et il ne l'assume pas et aujourd'hui il
y a la possibilité de retourner sur un
vote qui pour l'instant n'a pas eu lieu
c'est une des rares réformes de cette
importance où il n'y a jamais eu de vote
du Parlement jamais le seul vote qui a
eu lieu qui est celui contre la
mentionne ceinture ne portez pas sur le
débat du passage à 64 ans mais sûr
est-ce qu'il faut ou pas renverser le
gouvernement Juliette qui vous a
convaincu
[Musique]
mais je ne pense pas moi je pense que le
gouvernement est le la majorité ne
perdra pas le vote les calculs ont été
fait et par ailleurs si le 49-3 était à
nouveau saisi et bien le gouvernement
retrouverait sa majorité elle serait
probablement encore moins confortable
qu'elle ne l'a été la dernière fois mais
je crois qu'il ne l'a pas est-ce que le
donc on parlait du vote qui se tiendrait
éventuellement jeudi c'est vraiment ça
dont le gouvernement a peur c'est une
éventuelle défaite face au parlementaire
face à l'Assemblée nationale je pense
qu'ils avaient commencé d'ailleurs à le
dire dans le débat en préparant les
mentalités en disant voilà si un texte à
l'Assemblée il peut passer au Sénat il
sera retoqué et après
il ne serait pas constitutionnel donc
ils avaient préparé une défaite ils ont
changé stratégie mais pourquoi là c'est
là où je partage que vous disiez c'est
que ils ont pataugé depuis le début sur
la stratégie sur quel véhicule comment
l'a fait-on passer à quoi sert-elle et
surtout là même les quatre de la
majorité nous le disait cette semaine
ils n'ont pas vu venir cette PPL liotte
et cette bataille de la communication
voilà cette propos sur moi pardon elle a
été déposée le 25 avril pendant les
vacances parlementaires il y a pas eu de
filtre à cette proposition de loi et
donc on se retrouve avec un débat qui
les a totalement débordé et il patoche
vraiment parce qu'ils avaient plusieurs
stratégies l'obstruction faire tomber
l'article premier ce qu'ils ont réussi à
faire l'article phare de l'artiste de
proposition de Loire ou dire dans le
débat public qu'ils allaient perdre et
assumer cette défaite qui aurait été une
défaite je trouve que dans tous les cas
leur stratégie elle n'est pas du tout
gagnante parce que le gouvernement met
en avant c'est le coût d'un éventuel
abrogation de cette réforme des
retraites et éventuellement si cette loi
est votée on va voir donc cet argument
du gouvernement coût de l'abrogation de
la réforme des retraites 15 milliards
d'euros en fait abroger la réforme ça
reviendrait annuler les économies quel
promet de faire c'est valable comme
argument ça
ça ressorti à l'évidence puisque c'est
précisément le bénéfice principal de la
réforme si on considère que c'est un
bénéfice c'est que elle utiliser
d'économiser 15 milliards donc
évidemment si vous annulez les réformes
vous reperdez les 15 milliards donc
c'est un argument qui est très puissant
maintenant c'est pas l'alpha et l'oméga
de la discussion sur l'opportunité de
travailler plus ou pas mais c'est un
fait qu'à partir du moment
de financer nos retraites là on n'est
pas du tout dans cet argument là on est
que dans la politique c'est ce que vous
êtes en train de dire non enfin c'est de
la politique mais c'est également de la
réalité enfin encore une fois c'est très
fort des retraites faut se mettre à la
place de tout gouvernement d'ailleurs
tous les gouvernements précédents de
gauche et de droite ont apporté leur
petite pierre à la nécessaire réforme
des retraites personne le fait de
manière suffisamment définitive pour
qu'on n'est pas à y revenir
malheureusement mais tout le monde l'a
fait pourquoi tout le monde l'a fait
alors que c'est toujours un populaire
parce que c'est nécessaire et donc
effectivement il faut économiser ces 15
milliards ici on a si on abroche une
réforme qui permettait de les récupérer
par définition on les perd à nouveau
faudra les trouver ailleurs et
honnêtement pardon parce que je vais
faire mon petit numéro d'économiste
pendant 20 secondes on dit pas assez que
cette réforme elle a pas seulement comme
intérêt de rééquilibrer le dispositif
parce que vous avez des gens qui partent
plutôt à la retraite donc qui cotisent
plus longtemps et il touche moins de
retraite pendant leur vie de retraité ça
c'est c'est l'effet mécanique évident il
y a quelque chose qui est très important
c'est que en travaillant en plus pas
beaucoup d'ailleurs je vous rappelle que
ça fait 11 portes de gens qui
travailleront en moyenne deux trimestres
de plus il y a pas de quoi se relever la
nuit mais malgré tout d'un point de vue
macronique macroéconomique ça fait plus
de travail mobilisés c'est la recette de
la croissance donc ce pays souffre de
pas assez de croissance qui d'ailleurs
empêche de faire de la distribution qui
empêche d'être compétitif donc c'est ça
qu'il faut voir c'est pas seulement
qu'on va économiser en quelque sorte ses
combats créer de la richesse parce que
il y aura plus de gens qui travaillent
un peu plus mais si on reprend le fond
de l'affaire c'est pourquoi cette
réforme était à mon avis absolument
inacceptable c'est qu'il touchait avant
tout les classes populaires les gens qui
font pour une raison toute simple c'est
que quelqu'un qui fait des études qui va
jusqu'à une licence ou un master il
commence sa carrière professionnelle à
21-22 ans vous rajoutez 41-42 et 43
maintenant à cause des réformes
touraines qui y compris sont accélérées
quelqu'un qui a fait des études il ne
part jamais à 62 ans bon et donc il part
déjà à 64 ans 65 ans 66 ans pour prendre
un exemple personnel j'ai pris ma
retraite à 66 ans pour ces raisons là et
je suis sûr que beaucoup d'entre vous je
vais travailler 6 mois de plus mais je
ne pleure pas ce que je veux dire
ceux qui sont les victimes c'est ceux
qui ont commencé à travailler 18 19 20
ans c'est cela qui paye l'addition d'une
certaine façon c'est ça qui était
insupportable dans cette affaire
toute petite minorité une toute petite
et derrière ça je pense que sur cette
argument précis de du moment du
gouvernement c'est que le fait que cette
économies
le texte porté par le groupe iote serein
constitutionnel je pense que le
gouvernement va avoir des problèmes
parce qu'il a choisi un véhicule
législatif assez particulier pour
présenter cette loi qui est un une
correction disons à la loi de finances
de la sécurité sociale qui ne peut
porter que sur l'année 2023 et c'est
pour cette raison d'ailleurs que le
Conseil constitutionnel a rejeté tous
les cavaliers législatifs du type
l'index seniors et autres bricoles du
même genre bricoles entre guillemets
mais il a rejeté tout ça parce que ça me
concerne que 2023 en 2023 le bénéfice de
la réforme sera évidemment pas de 15
milliards la réforme ne s'appliquera
qu'en septembre elle va toucher très peu
de gens et donc
c'est quelques centaines de millions et
donc considérer à cause du véhicule
législatif que c'est une perte sur le
budget de l'ordre de 15 milliards n'est
pas la réalité liée au fond là
j'aimerais vraiment qu'on se concentre
sur l'aspect politique je vais prendre
beaucoup de notes juillet vous avez
beaucoup beaucoup de choses à dire il y
a une vraie un vrai eSport de d'abroger
cette réforme des retraites où là on est
vraiment dans le symbole non je crois
qu'on est vraiment dans le symbole je
pense que les la France insoumise
gesticulent pousse à la faute cherche à
cliver
que la France insoumise évidemment c'est
son intérêt principal à pousser le
groupe pilote en avant donc Charles de
Courson qui s'est illustré par sa
soudaine velléité de révolte contre
l'ordre établi et qui ne pourfant et qui
est actuellement pour fond l'équilibre
des finances publiques ce qui jamais été
sa ligne enfin peu importe donc tout ça
est un jeu dupe la stratégie de la
France insoumise c'est de pousser à
nouveau à ce qui est un débat extrême et
quand je dis un débat extrême moi je
suis complètement favorable au débat je
pense que ça nous nourrit sauf que là le
débat à la sauce Jean-Luc Mélenchon
dessert l'envie pour les citoyens de se
plonger dans ce qui fait leur le sens de
leur engagement pourquoi parce que tout
ça devient insultant disqualifiant pour
toute la classe politique excessif et
injurieux et donc finalement ça dessert
tout le monde a-t-elle enseigne qu'on
voit que la France insoumise aujourd'hui
est en train de baisser dans les
sondages et que le citoyen se détourne
du débat public hélas et ce tourne vers
qui vers le rassemblement national ce
qui est au passage est exactement la
stratégie de Jean-Luc Mélenchon il veut
être face à Marine Le Pen en 2027
à qui ça profite sur les retraites oui
mais
pratiquement on voit que depuis le début
ça ne sert que le RN qui a été
totalement silencieux sur le sujet qui
n'a fait aucune proposition crédible et
qui n'a cessé de monter dans les
sondages donc je trouve que pour le
gouvernement c'est assez cacophonique
effectivement ils n'ont pas vu venir
cette réouverture de débats et même si
dans le fond la loi est promulguée on
sait qu'elle va passer c'est plus une
question de légitimité encore de cette
réforme et de débat de cacophonie et de
c'est donc ça ne sert pas la vie
politique la confiance des Français dans
la vie politique je vous rejoins
parfaitement et ça aide le RN ça c'est
sûr je pense que la précisément on va
parler du RN si vous voulez bien comment
lutter contre l'ascension du
rassemblement national c'est notre
deuxième thème et encore quelques temps
la lutte contre l'extrême droite faisait
plutôt consensus la méthode dite du
cordon sanitaire servait à rassembler le
camp républicain contre un ennemi commun
mais cette semaine au sein même du
couple exécutif il y a eu comme une
friture sur la ligne écoutez
je crois pas du tout à la normalisation
du rassemblement national je pense qu'il
faut pas banaliser ses idées ses idées
sont toujours les mêmes alors maintenant
le rassemblement national il met les
formes mais je pense continuer à penser
que c'est une idéologie
de Pétain Marine Le Pen pareil je pense
que je n'ai jamais entendu Marine Le Pen
dénonçait ce qu'on peut être les
positions historiques de son de son
parti et je pense que un changement de
non ne change pas les idées des racines
recadrage immédiat d'Emmanuel Macron le
combat contre l'extrême droite ne passe
plus par des arguments moraux vous
n'arriverez pas à faire croire à des
millions de Français qui ont voté pour
l'extrême droite que ce sont des
fascistes c'est peut-être Emmanuel
Macron en conseil des ministres cette
semaine c'est la fin du consensus sur la
méthode à adopter face au rassemblement
national Juliette mais d'abord il y a
jamais eu de consensus et ça fait 25 ans
que on constate une difficulté de toutes
parts à lutter contre les arguments
national pourquoi parce que vous
souvenez des cinéma avec Bernard Tapie
on avait à l'époque on avait considéré
qu'il y avait seulement Bernard Tapie
qui arrivait au front pas François
Mitterrand absolument et qui avait c'est
vrai magistralement gagné ce combat
contre Jean-Marie Le Pen à l'époque
qu'est-ce qui se passe 25 ans plus tard
on sent que on a toujours un peu de mal
à combattre et à convaincre les Français
que les arguments du rassemblement
national aujourd'hui sont inopérants
donc je trouve qui est en réalité de
différence d'approches entre le
Président de la République et la
première ministre le président a
totalement raison de dire que on ne
combattra pas le rassemblement national
avec de la morale vous allez pas
convaincre quelqu'un qu'il a eu tort de
voter que c'est pas bien et qu'il est un
fasciste c'est vrai ce qu'il dit et
c'est vrai aussi que le rassemblement
national aujourd'hui
à juste hippolyné sa façade donc à la
raison la première ministre de dire que
finalement derrière cette espèce de
façade de respectabilité on reste sur
des programmes contre l'égalité et
contre la fraternité après vous nous
faites du en même temps j'aimerais
écouter Christophe à ce sujet vous êtes
d'accord Emmanuel Macron a raison sur ce
point sur la manière de lutter contre le
rassemblement national
je partage assez ce que vous venez de
dire c'est à dire que les deux pour moi
s'opposent pas bon et je pense qu'on est
en train de faire monter en épingle
quelque chose qui relève plus d'un
règlement de compte entre guillemets ou
en tout cas d'une tension politique
interne au gouvernement plus que des
questions de fond bon bien évidemment il
faut contrer le Front national sur ces
propositions actuelles bon et on ne peut
pas penser une seule seconde que des
dizaines de millions de Français ont
envie de rentrer dans la milice ou dans
les voies faits SS ça tient pas debout
donc ça on est bien d'accord en même
temps l'origine l'histoire des
dirigeants et de la façon dont le front
nationalité créé évidemment un objet par
exemple précisément il faut les Français
il est quand même utile mais derrière ça
moi ce qui m'inquiète plus hein pour
rentrer dans la politique actuelle c'est
le fait que beaucoup dans la sphère
politique commence à se rapprocher des
thèses du Front national soi-disant pour
les convaincre prenez sur l'immigration
la proposition du parti républicain
c'est quand même incroyable que ce
parti-là sur toute une série de sujets
dit qu'il faut rompre avec les règles de
l'Union européenne et d'Acco européenne
des droits de l'homme c'est quand même
fort de café de voir un parti qui est un
parti de gouvernement qui a géré la
France
en disant c'est pas il est pas question
de sortir de lui je m'en doute ils sont
pas fous mais ça veut dire que ils
prennent des positions qui sont
strictement celles du RN et comme on
voit Gérard dahmanin qui dit maintenant
il faut négocier les républicains pour
trouver un accord qui sera évidemment
sur cette ligne là en plus inquiéter ça
ça m'inquiète plus débat si on peut
appeler ça débat entre Elisabeth borne
et Emmanuel Macron ça traduit la
normalisation d'une certaine manière du
parti
du RN du rassemblement national
oui effectivement c'est sous la remonte
c'est sous cette législature que le RN
débarque à l'Assemblée avec 9 députés
donc on voit bien que ça fait voler un
peu en éclat tout ce qui Emmanuel Macron
avait réussi à installer dans son match
vous parlez de Bernard Tapie Emmanuel
Macron a quand même été un des derniers
à avoir réussi à montrer l'impréparation
de Marine Le Pen souvenez-vous de ce
grand débat lui lui a réussi non pas par
des actes mais au moins par un
corps à corps lors du débat télévisé a
prouvé que Marine Le Pen n'était pas
bien préparé à ce moment-là donc ça
c'est bon il a réussi maintenant moi
j'ai envie de dire ce qu'il dit c'est il
devrait pas le dire à ciel ouvert on n'a
pas besoin de dire pour gagner le contre
le RN il faut des actes faites-le et on
voit tout il a quand même le moi je suis
quand même très sensible à l'argument
massif du président qui est de dire on a
face à nous l'incompétence organisée
avec justement on va écouter Emmanuel
Macron je vous donne la forme qui est
revenu sur les propos qu'il a prononcé
en conseil des ministres et là redit sa
confiance en Elizabeth borne ce que j'ai
toujours combattu c'est des mensonges et
les dénuds de réalité qui sont fait
utiliser par les extrêmes mais en
particulier l'extrême droite on ne peut
plus battre dans nos démocraties
l'extrême droite simplement avec des
arguments historiques et moraux quand
est-ce que j'ai pu entendre sur madame
la Première ministre je veux ici lui
redire toute ma confiance et je savais
j'ai eu un mode de fonctionnement simple
quand j'ai des choses à dire les
premiers ministres depuis 6 ans je le
dis dans un colloque singulier dont rien
ne sort
et nous réglons les choses ensemble je
ne fais jamais autour de la table du
Conseil des ministres par
média interposés vous y croyez Juliette
mais oui j'y crois quand on est c'est
criants de vérité ce qu'il dit je crois
pas du tout que le débat sur le front
national soit le reflet
de confiance à porter à Isabelle bord
vraiment sur l'aspect politique vous
savez comment ça se passe
que je voulais dire ici quand même c'est
que c'est vrai que la principale menace
c'est le rassemblement national et je
trouve qu'il y a des arguments qu'on
devrait beaucoup plus mettre en avant on
pourrait quand même bien montrer que le
rassemblement national il parti de la
haine de la France parce que ça se sent
quand vous êtes regardez leurs
argumentaires il ne cesse de critiquer
et l'histoire de notre pays et notre
service public et l'État rien à grâce à
leurs yeux et la deuxième chose qu'on ne
met pas c'est en avant c'est les liens
intrinsèque et viseraux de Marine Le Pen
avec des pays qui nous détestent
j'accompagne de Marine Le Pen les
européennes pour le coup ça va être
vraiment l'occasion de faire ça l'année
prochaine
à faire vous inspire cette histoire
cette affaire Borge cette question alors
sans même parler de l'opportunité de le
faire maintenant ou plus tard je pensais
une question qui est fondamentale
comment on lutte contre le rassemblement
national ou le Front national auparavant
moi c'est un sujet je veux qu'elle
pardon j'avais écrit il y a une
vingtaine d'années c'est pas la peine de
faire de la morale parce que
effectivement leur programme est
ridicule alors ce qui est très
intéressant c'est qu'à l'époque le
programme était ridicule parce qu'il
était tellement libéral que il
détruisait la base imposable c'était
lunaire c'est que l'équipe avait lu les
les économistes américains mais un peu
de travers il savait pas pardon que le
zéro était absorbant donc ici on
supprime hier ça va faire augmenter un
peu sur la recette fiscale donc déjà
c'était débile mais au moins c'était
débile pardonnez-moi j'ai mes mon point
de vue libéral maintenant c'est débile
quasi communiste faut quand même pas
oublier que maintenant le le programme
du du rassemblement national il est très
établiste alors de ce point de vue là et
pas du tout pour des raisons historiques
il y a quelque chose effectivement qui a
été un lien avec c'est à dire que la
collectivité va faire quelque chose pour
l'individu il y a cette espèce de
promesse c'est à mon avis le seul point
qui permet de le rattacher à l'histoire
parce que sincèrement aujourd'hui enfin
d'ailleurs vous avez vu c'est pas c'est
pas Elisabeth borne qui parle de Pétain
c'est son interviewer
évidemment qui pourrait dire non dans
cette circonstance on va pas dire bah
non il a rien à voir il a rien à voir
avec Pétain c'est pas c'est même pas
disciple donc c'est pas pour la défendre
elle mais c'est c'est la question de
l'interviewer qui amène sur le sujet moi
je pense que
historiquement tout a changé
c'est-à-dire que sincèrement il y a 25
ans le nombre de gens qui étaient au
rassemblement national était pas très
élevé au Front National et leur
idéologie était très homogène et elle
était effectivement très héritière on
parle de pétanque on pourrait parler
aussi de l'os on fait une espèce de
vision du monde on peut qualifier de
fasciste pour aller pour aller vite la
journée
il a beaucoup qui sont morts ces
électeurs là c'est militants là il y en
a beaucoup qui sont morts pardon je suis
très trivial mais bon il en reste et
évidemment Marine Le Pen qui à mon avis
n'a pas la moindre opinion ni là-dessus
ni sur quoi que ce soit d'autre ne va
pas les chasser mais c'est vestigial au
sens et littéral du terme ce qui fait le
succès du rassemblement national c'est
un petit peu l'héritage pétaniste au
sens que je l'ai dit c'est dire c'est
promesse d'un État qui protège les corps
et cette espèce de mais c'est pas
fasciste ça c'est ridicule et à mon avis
c'est parfaitement inadapté aux besoins
du pays mais c'est pas fasciste en soi
c'est la promesse du rassemblement
national aujourd'hui elle est plus faite
pour séduire le gilet jaune l'habitant
semi rural qui se sent à tort ou à
raison abandonné avec les services
publics le coût de gazole etc il sait
c'est ça la promesse du rassemblement
national et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
qu'elle marche parce qu'il y a beaucoup
de gens qui sont intéressés
il y a des arguments moraux qui restent
mais ils sont de moins en moins
pertinents parce que le parti tout
simplement a changé dans sa composition
et surtout ce ne sont pas les plus
importants si on veut convaincre les
électeurs du rassemblement national de
ne pas voter pour l'ensemble national
donc en fait c'est un débat il faut les
prendre sur l'identité et leur
attachement à la France moi je suis
frappée par ce discours de environnement
général du rassemblement national sur ce
que nous sommes nous sommes la
République qui est fraternelle et égale
et égale sur quoi le Front national se
distingue-t-il ou le rassemblement
national c'est qu'il déteste l'égalité
et il déteste la fraternité c'est quand
même un comble qu'on n'arrive pas à
convaincre sur ce point de vue là et
c'est aussi un comble qu'on n'arrive pas
à convaincre que quand on soutient
jusqu'à l'invasion de l'Ukraine quand on
soutient Vladimir Poutine quand on suit
financé par la Hongrie quand on soutient
d'autres dictatures qui détestent tout
ce qu'incarne la France et ben on n'aime
pas la France je pense qu'en gros
social cette semaine le gouvernement a
dévoilé son plan pour lutter contre les
fraudeurs et ses Gabriel Attal le
ministre des comptes publics qui est
monté au créneau écoutez-le
je cherche pas instrumentaliser ou à
stigmatiser qui que ce soit je cherche
les fraudes pas les gens qui sont
derrière les fraudes donc je regarde où
est-ce qu'il y a des fraudes et j'essaye
d'apporter des réponses effectivement
sans stigmatisation sans
instrumentalisation comme ça peut être
le cas dans certains partis politiques
donc encore une fois moi je sigmatise
pas je dis pas que tous les
professionnels de santé ou tous les
pharmaciens ou tous les centres de santé
fraude je dis qu'il y a des fraudes et
qu'il faut les identifier qu'il faut y
répondre parce que c'est le meilleur
moyen de redonner confiance aux Français
dans notre modèle social un plan contre
la fraude sociale qui prévoit notamment
une éventuelle fusion entre la carte
vitale et la carte d'identité
l'obligation de résider 9 mois en France
contre six actuellement pour toucher les
allocations le renforcement des
contrôles des retraités vivants hors
d'Europe ou encore le doublement des
contrôles des entreprises Christophe la
front social c'est un vrai sujet
aujourd'hui en France c'est toujours un
vrai sujet quand il y a entre 8 et 16
milliards d'argent qui disparaissent
c'est vrai bon personne ne peut
évidemment le nier la question c'est de
savoir qui fait c'est qui est
responsable cette faute sociale d'où
elle vient la principale c'était le
travail non déclaré historique c'était
les petits PME artisans dont une partie
des choses passées sous le manteau ce
qui était à la fois une fraude fiscale
évidemment à la TVA et au bénéfice des
sociétés et une faute sociale parce
qu'on payait pas d'Urf bon ça continue
heureusement ça diminue parce qu'il y a
plus de contrôle y compris même sur les
particuliers le fait d'avoir fait le
chèque emploi service facilite les
choses par rapport à la situation
auparavant ou pour deux heures de ménage
les gens allaient pas déclaré des choses
à dursaff donc les choses s'améliorent
un peu mais il en reste mais quand on
regarde ceux qui sont concernés la
moitié c'est des noms cotisations
versées c'est-à-dire ce qui reste de
cette de ce travail non déclaré donc de
l'ordre de 8 milliards si on compte 16
milliards sur les 8 milliards restants
il y a 4 milliards qui viennent de
choses qui sont sur la sécurité sociale
et qui pour l'essentiel viennent des
professionnels et pas des individus donc
c'est pas en fusionnant carte d'identité
carte Vitale qu'on résoudra le problème
c'est simplement des médecins ou autre
qui augmentent un peu le nombre de
prestations parce que ça permet
d'augmenter clairement un vrai sujet
pour vous la frontière le problème c'est
que ça n'est pas de ça dont il parle le
gouvernement c'est ça moi qui m'inquiète
dans la fleur rapidement
le ministre du Travail du socle a
reconnu que pour l'essentiel c'est le
travail non déclaré mais ce sur quoi il
table c'est évidemment les gens qui
étant décédé laissent leur famille
toucher leur retraite évidemment il faut
lutter contre ça ça pose aucun problème
je pensais que c'était fait j'imaginais
pas que ça fiche continuer et on parlait
de la Corse
politique
les pauvres vieux travailleurs
maghrébins qui rentrent chez eux avec
une petite retraite et qu'on les laisse
pas bénéficier de ça alors que ça touche
toute petite somme parce qu'il ne s'agit
pas de la retraite heureusement les gens
peuvent garder leur retraite et vivent à
l'étranger le nombre de Français qui
vivent au Portugal ou au Maroc parce
qu'il fait plus beau qu'en France il y
en a quand même on revient sur la chaîne
politique c'est uniquement la petite
partie qui concerne le minimum
vieillesse mais c'est tout à fait
marginal vient d'avoir un langage très
pragmatique je ne cherche pas à
stigmatiser les gens je vais faire des
économies non c'est un coup politique on
parlait de braconnage des thèmes du RN
l'assistanat c'est un grand discours de
la droite c'est un irritant chez les
Français les Français ils sont très
sensibles moi je rentre pas dans la
légitimité du débat ou non mais donc
Gabriel Attal a proposé un projet très
c'est très fin politiquement c'est je
parle de fraude sociale et je parle de
fraude fiscale comme ça vous m'accuserez
pas de parler soit de l'un soit de
l'autre parce qu'on a tendance à les
opposer c'est vrai quand vous parlez de
fraude sociale tout le monde va vous
dire mais attendez quand on prend les
ordres de grandeur la fraude sociale
c'est rien c'est 8 milliard l'autre
c'est 100 médias donc ne parlons pas des
mêmes choses il y a la France insoumise
d'un côté et il y a le RN donc là il
fait un projet en même temps froide
social fraude fiscal sauf que on va
quand même sur les terres du Front
National et de la droite et de se débat
est ciotis sur sur l'assistanat social
donc est-ce qu'on doit flatter le peuple
dans ces bases instincts je ne suis pas
sûr est-ce que ces économies permettront
de sauver
la France et ses finances publiques je
suis pas certaine non plus juste le
chiffre Juliette c'est effectivement ça
a été mentionné plusieurs fois la fraude
sociale aujourd'hui c'est 8 milliards
d'euros par an selon un rapport de la
Cour des comptes Philippe une manière de
s'une manière de de flatter un certain
électorat à droite à l'extrême droite
absolument ça l'est incontestablement
mais ça n'est pas que ça alors d'abord
ça n'est pas que ça c'est à dire que moi
je suis quand même étonné qu'on se pose
la question de l'opportunité de lutter
contre la fraude Christophe le disait on
pensait que c'était fait à bien des
égards oui mais il y a aussi des
questions de moyens il y a la technique
et puis il y avait une tolérance de
certaines administrations que ce soit
d'ailleurs la fraude des employeurs ou
que ce soit la fraude sociale des de
monsieur et madame tout le monde tout ça
moi à mon avis mérite d'être remis
d'aplomb parce que tout simplement en
état de droit personne ne peut se
satisfaire de la fraude enfin
l'opportunité même de lutter contre la
fraude je comprenais même pas qu'on la
discute un instant donc ça c'est vrai me
semble-t-il maintenant comme ça l'était
avant et plus on lutte contre la fraude
mieux ça vaut ou bien alors on croit pas
l'état de droit encore une fois après
est-ce que effectivement il y a un coût
politique et est-ce que alors je
prendrai pas l'expression que vous aviez
utilisé de flotter les bases instincts
parce que il y a une demande vous le
disiez il y a une vraie question
beaucoup de Français se disent oui mais
moi je bosse et puis il y en a d'autres
ne bosse pas et qui et qui ont des
allocations moins ils auront cette
opinion-là mieux ça vaudra je pense
qu'on en sera d'accord donc plus on
lutte contre l'afro des moins il y a
d'exemples sous leurs yeux mieux ça vaut
et après je rebouk avec ce qu'on disait
avant et ensuite j'en ai fini si on veut
lutter contre le rassemblement national
autrement qu'avec les fantasmes de l'OAS
de Pétain ou de la vapen SS comme ils
étaient Christophe c'est pas inutile
effectivement de faire quelque chose
parce que le Front national on peut être
assez facilement d'accord sur le fait
qu'il y a des choses qu'il dit ou qu'il
fait qui ne sont pas opportunes c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire mais si le Front
national vous dit qu'il fait beau
aujourd'hui et qu'il fait beau on va pas
dire qu'il fait mauvais juste pour le
contrarier on a sur ce point le Front
national conduit me semble-t-il à une
analyse qui n'est pas complètement
fausse quand il dit qu'il voudrait il
faudrait éviter la fraude et c'est pas
parce que le Front national le dit qu'il
faut pas le faire alors en revanche si
c'était ciblé spécifiquement sur
certaines populations dont on sait que
le Front national des stigmatismes
volontiers ce serait problématique
généralement prudent
est-ce qu'on a attendu Gabriel Attal
pour lutter contre la fraude sociale
c'est un peu ce qu'il se dit voilà c'est
un truc qui fait qu'on s'inscrire non
attendez ce qui est vrai c'est que on
n'a jamais réussi à lutter vraiment
efficacement contre la fraude sociale et
contre la fraude fiscale et donc porter
ce sujet là maintenant c'est bien venu
c'est bien venu dans un pays qui ne vote
plus dans un pays où il y a une crise
dans la relation de confiance avec les
pouvoirs publics et dans un pays oui ou
le rassemblement national est Éric
Zemmour et des discours qu'on trouve
aussi à l'ultra gauche ne cesse de
monter pour disloquer contre
complètement l'État nation et la
protection sociale donc c'est bien venu
et c'est aussi une façon pour le
ministre des comptes publics qu'il est
de dire on doit être nous état plus
efficace dans la lutte contre la fraude
sociale et fiscale donc c'est le bon
moment de le faire c'est quand même
assez courageux parce que certains lui
disent bah pourquoi vous ne l'avez pas
fait dans les cinq dernières années donc
je trouve que c'est plutôt courageux de
le dire et enfin moi j'ai pas vu
contrairement à vous un ciblage de
population en particulier pourquoi dans
ce discours contre la fraude fiscale il
a ciblé aussi les grandes fortunes et
dans son discours contre la fraude
sociale il cible les entreprises qui
fraudent l'URSSAF et qui embauche aussi
des travailleurs irréguliers en
situation de précarité donc je ne trouve
pas que le discours soit déséquilibré je
trouve que c'est un discours bienvenu et
pour finir ça n'est pas la fraude
sociale et fiscale ça n'est pas le thème
du RN c'est le thème de tous les
citoyens de la gauche aussi nous nous
l'avons défendu alors
union nationale des oeuvres et
organismes privées non lucratif a publié
un communiqué qu'on va voir un
communiqué dans lequel elle dénonce une
communication stigmatisante à l'encontre
des plus précaires Christophe vous êtes
d'accord avec ça il y a un vrai sujet
parce que derrière le discours et c'est
vrai qu'on écoute Gabriel Attal ça a
l'air équilibré bon
après qu'on regarde ceux qui fraudent
vraiment est-ce que vraiment vous pensez
que le gouvernement va s'attaquer au
médecin avec la crise de santé qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui évidemment non
est-ce que vous pensez qu'ils vont
s'attaquer on va on va voir maintenant
c'est prévu
mais au contraire mieux au contrôle est
mieux accompagnés c'est évidemment une
sub qui est compliqué aujourd'hui vu les
tensions dans le secteur de la santé
vous prenez maintenant tout ce qui est
PME artisan etc vu les difficultés dans
la construction et dans le logement là
aussi je pense que tout le monde va y
aller [__] douce donc ce qui va rester
c'est ce que dit Bruno Le Maire
c'est-à-dire qu'on va en effet
s'intéresser au maghrébin qui est rentré
chez lui avec une toute petite retraite
pour vérifier qui est pas sur sa
retraite de 3700 euros 100 euros qui
relève du minimum vieillesse donc il n'a
pas le droit de toucher s'il ne reste
pas au moins 6 mois en France demain 9
mois bon et là il y a de la
stigmatisation
mais on peut se dire quand même que là
il y a eu pour la première fois des
annonces au moment de la des annonces
sur la fraude fiscale qui ciblait les
grandes fortunes ce qui du coup était
quand même assez inédit et même chose
sur la fraude sociale moi je crois que
en fait probablement on peut espérer que
les pouvoirs publics iront vers là où la
lutte contre la fraude rapportera le
plus
ça rapportera beaucoup plus de lutter
contre la fraude des entreprises aux
URSSAF ou de lutter contre la fraude
notamment des plus grosses fortunes à
l'évasion fiscale qui est quand même un
thème qui a été aussi mis dans le débat
public ça rapportera beaucoup plus et
donc on peut tout faire pour que ce soit
les grandes lignes de la lutte contre la
fraude juste un mot sur ce que j'écris
ça absolument d'accord il faut pas
stigmatiser mais stigmatiser refusé de
stigmatiser ça veut pas dire protéger
particulièrement une population que
quelqu'un de mal intentionné voudrait
stigmatiser à tort si par exemple vous
avez effectivement un travailleur
immigré qui se trouverait être reparti
chez lui et qui touche indument parce
que là encore il y a des critères qui
sont simples c'est la loi c'est simple
que ça si les parties et que la loi fait
qu'il a pas droit à ses 100 euros de
supplément on va pas parce qu'il faut
pas le stigmatiser lui donner en plus
vous voyez bien que c'est pas le sujet
on parle de politique là c'est très
efficace parce que les gens c'est ça et
efficacité et de performance de l'action
publique et de la fraude fiscale
mais c'est pas ça dont on parle vous
n'avez pas aujourd'hui suffisamment de
fonctionnaires pour que le contrôle soit
systématique et sur tout le monde donc
les pouvoirs publics vont être obligés
de prioriser la lutte contre fiscalement
contrôler tout le monde puisque c'est de
ça qu'on parle directement même si c'est
tout petit dans l'ensemble on en est
tous d'accord c'est ça qui politiquement
est le plus sensible il faut pas se
raconter l'histoire c'est aussi pour
répondre à cette demande vous le disiez
qui est très importante dans tous les
sondages d'opinion c'est pour ça aussi
que il y a tout cet ensemble qui est qui
est mis en oeuvre c'est de lutter aussi
contre la petite fraude de gens qui
donnent le sentiment aux autres qu'ils
tirent la qui tire la couverture à eux
si c'est la loi qui n'est pas respectée
il n'y a absolument rien de scandaleux à
faire respecter la loi et encore il y a
des problèmes atypiques qui sont très
bêtes mais typiquement quelqu'un qui
prend sa retraite à l'étranger on ne
sait pas toujours quand il est mort
c'est pas facile donc ces sujets à
l'étranger qu'on les traite moi je
trouve ça complètement normal il y a pas
de stigmatisation
l'étranger direction l'Espagne le pays
est en route vers un nouveau scrutin
législatif au mois de juillet c'est le
chef du gouvernement actuel le
socialisme Pedro Sanchez qu'il y a
décidé de convoquer des élections
anticipées une décision prise
immédiatement après la déroute de son
parti aux élections locales de dimanche
dernier écoutez pour les choses
en tant que président du gouvernement et
secrétaire du Parti socialiste j'assume
les résultats et je pense qu'il est
nécessaire de donner une réponse et de
soumettre notre mandat démocratique à la
volonté populaire
infaillible pour résoudre les doutes et
cette méthode c'est la démocratie par
conséquent je pense que la meilleure
chose à faire et que les Espagnols
prennent la parole et se déclarent son
délai pour fixer le cours politique du
pays
inscrit un local dimanche une annonce
d'élection anticipée dimanche soir il y
a quoi être jaloux quand on voit ce qui
se passe en Espagne
cette rapidité à revenir devant les
élections devant les électeurs redonner
la parole au peuple il a c'est un geste
d'une finesse politique effectivement à
souligner parce que il était de toute
façon presque condamnée puisque à la fin
de l'année il doit y avoir des élections
mais ça devait être descendre devait y
avoir des informations il savait que
c'était très compliqué pour lui au sein
de sa propre coalition c'est compliqué
et de toute façon le Parti populaire
évoque c'est extrême droite ont
effectivement gagné énormément de
terrain donc là c'est un peu un coup de
la dernière chance dire j'anticipe comme
ça je on va essayer de remobiliser la
gauche et on va pas laisser le temps
parce que en Espagne c'est un système
par coalition on peut commanditalie on
va pas laisser le temps à VOX et au
Parti populaire de s'entendre être de
réussir leur coalition donc c'est un
c'est à la fois opération dernière
chance et c'est quand même un coût
politique majeur et moi ça me fait
penser à c'est vrai qu'il y en a plus
beaucoup des leaders sociaux de
démocrates qui ont son envergure je me
suis en 2014 j'étais à Bologne à
l'époque je suivais c'était l'image
phare
Sanchez Valls et Matteo Renzi bon lui il
est arrivé au pouvoir plus tard en 2018
Sanchez mais quand même c'est un des
derniers à résister et c'est vrai que
c'était la c'était la force de la
social-démocratie Olivier Faure et aller
le voir il y a pas longtemps et c'est un
modèle c'est pour beaucoup mais pas
certain de dire quelque chose et là je
trouve que il a incarné une vraie
responsabilité politique je vais vous
montrer les résultats des élections
comme les résultats des élections
municipales espagnoles avec le Parti
populaire donc la droite qui a fait
31,5% le Parti socialiste qui est arrivé
deuxième avec 28,1% évoque l'extrême
droite avec
7,19% et puis il y avait des élections
régionales qui ont donné la victoire de
la droite dans 6 des 10 régions dirigées
par les socialistes Christophe qu'est-ce
que ça vous inspire ce retour aux urnes
précipité par ces résultats je pense
aussi que c'est un coup politique assez
malin de la part du du chef du
gouvernement espagnol ce qu'il faut voir
c'est qu'en fait ni le Parti populaire
ni le psee n'en gagné tant que ça ou on
perd du temps que ça le parti popul un
peu gagner mais né qu'à 32 donc il est
loin d'une majorité absolue il participe
a perdu un peu mais enfin 28% le Parti
socialiste français quelques autres
seraient assez heureux de garder cette
envergure électorale là ce qui s'est
passé c'est que à gauche le Parti
socialiste était talonné par podemos qui
s'est effondré pour toute une série de
ces deux radicales c'est une série de
raisons c'est deux principaux dirigeants
ont arrêté où ont sisionné Pablo
Iglesias a arrêté la politique publique
en tout cas après son échec dans la
région de Madrid et le numéro 2 de
podomus et les Ron a lancé un nouveau
parti qui s'appelle les maspahis et qui
a fait une un accord avec d'autres
petits partis vers et lui a plutôt eu
des bons résultats mais pas suffisant
pour pouvoir prétendre à remplacer ce
qui était le podémose d'avant et puis de
l'autre côté à droite c'est la montée de
Vox parce que vous devez extrême droite
mais vraiment frankiste le lien avec le
passé Franco est beaucoup plus net
encore que ce qu'on dit tout à l'heure
sur le rassemblement national parce que
c'est aussi plus récent c'est jusqu'à 75
la dictature
il est à 15 % dans les régions bon
beaucoup plus que les 7% dans les villes
puisqu'on est Adil n'était pas présent
et aujourd'hui le PP est complètement
partagé sur le fait de savoir il faut
pas le Parti populaire donc la droite
classique s'il faut un accord ou pas
avec Vox il faut la prendre un peu la
vision européenne en Europe il y a
beaucoup de pays dans lequel l'alliance
droite extrême droite est réalisée
depuis longtemps c'est les pays du Nord
les pays scandinaves et puis l'Italie
surtout ou le Meloni n'est pas arrivé
par hasard c'est arrivé depuis
Berlusconi vous avez tout à fait raison
une alliance très très forte bon la
France et l'Allemagne résiste
heureusement il y a encore un peu de mur
qui résiste à cette alliance droite
extrême droite je sais pas combien de
temps ça durera mais en Espagne on est
dans un processus dans lequel cette
alliance était en train de se créer mais
avec des tensions
sur la méthode
et immédiatement on convoque et ça n'a
rien à l'avant encore une fois c'est des
élections locales et convoquent des
élections législatives ça fait rêver non
je sais pas ça n'arriverait jamais en
France quelque chose comme ça
je moi je suis un peu partagé avec ces
histoires de ça ressemble un peu du
tripatouage c'est un peu le problème
c'est à dire que quand vous vous mettez
à tripatouiller le calendrier
institutionnel pour
à la faveur d'un résultat électoral
politique
je préfère qu'on respecte je trouve que
c'est toujours mieux de respecter les
calendriers électoraux sauf cataclysme
évidemment non mais il y a des
calendriers qui sont prévus par les
institutions les institutions quand même
quelque chose de stable tout le monde
les connaît et donc
provoquer des élections en anticiper
alors qu'il y a pas eu une catastrophe
nucléaire je trouve que c'est toujours
un peu gênant du point de vue de la
confiance parce que le citoyen en plus
se dit bah j'ai je viens de voter alors
certes c'était une élection locale
et donc en réalité
que ça sert vraiment la confiance après
il y a un autre sujet c'est est-ce que
on peut s'inspirer de l'exemple espagnol
pour régler nos problématiques français
le thème de notre thème non non c'est
notre hôtel alors votre réponse alors ma
réponse est non parce que je pense que
les d'abord les systèmes ne sont pas
comparables nous en France on a quand
même voté il y a un an sur des élections
présidentielles puis sur des élections
législatives donc je trouve que si
demain le président disait bah on
retourne voter moi je pense que on
n'aurait pas grand chose de mieux que ce
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui en revanche il
y a quand même des choses qui te disent
fonctionnent dans notre système
politique et moi je serais assez
favorable puisque les gens ne viennent
plus voter aujourd'hui à dire il y a
l'élection présidentielle elle reste
l'élection maîtresse on la laisse comme
ça on la change pas mais en revanche on
propose de fusionner le jour des votes
pour les législatives et pour les
élections locales
réforme des institutions si vous voulez
ça serait beaucoup plus simple parce que
déjà on n'aurait pas comme je l'ai vécu
moins étant élu local on n'aurait pas
vécu des scrutins aux municipales où il
y a un français sur cinq seulement qui
est du voter et on pourrait comme ça
essayer d'avoir une forme de cohérence
entre l'action législative et l'action
locale Philippe qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de ce modèle est-ce qu'il y a un
modèle déjà espagnol mais qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de ce qui vient de se passer
en Espagne non mais d'abord sur le
caractère Juliette mettait sur la voie
de d'une analyse est-ce que c'est bien
respectueux des institutions est-ce que
c'est bien démocratique va honnêtement
la plus grande et la plus ancienne
démocratie du monde le Royaume-Uni fait
ça sans arrêt ils appellent élections
l'assemblée l'assemblée ils appellent à
des élections générales pour régler un
problème ou pour retremper leur
légitimité c'est parfaitement
complètement démocratique moi ça ne me
choque pas et j'allais dire ce qui
pourrait être choquant dans votre
logique c'est si c'était une espèce de
coup de force mais là il s'agit de dire
les gars je rends les clés aux électeurs
il faut bien ce qu'ils veulent ça me
paraît difficile de critiquer ça sous le
sous l'angle du défaut de démocratie
après il y a quand même une différence
fondamentale
[Musique]
au moment où il y avait au niveau de la
quatrième de confiance rentabilité moi
je crois que c'est pas la même chose
alors que les gens vont pas voter vous
croyez vraiment que ça va changer
quelque chose je dis pas que ça va
changer quelque chose j'ai dit
simplement que la plus grande démocratie
du monde fait ça très régulièrement
et voilà si je peux me permettre donc ça
c'est un point le deuxième point c'est
que on a dit à quel point l'Espagne la
France et le Royaume-Uni d'ailleurs
aussi tout ça n'est pas complètement
comparable il y a un point qui est quand
même important en Espagne c'est le poids
des régions pour les raisons qu'on sait
c'est en particulier le Pays Basque et
la Catalogne si vous perdez les
régionales dans un pays comme l'Espagne
qui est pas exactement un pays fédéral
mais qui a un pays où les régions jouent
un rôle si important c'est un sens
politique beaucoup plus important que
chez nous ou honnêtement perdre les
régionales enfin à part caser les
copains tout le monde s'en fiche un peu
du point de la politique nationale la
bas c'est pas tout à fait rien et pour
finir oui ce qu'il fait là c'est un coup
politique évidemment enfin la politique
on le sait bien c'est à la fois de la
dignité et de la turpitude c'est ça qui
on est bon quand on réussit à aligner
les deux en l'occurrence je trouve que
ça a une jungle les gars j'ai perdu les
régionales c'est quand même une
contrariété je vais demander aux
Espagnols de me donner une nouvelle
légitimité ou pas et puis c'est
évidemment un coup parce que
effectivement il vaut mieux anticiper
une élection qu'on est sûr de perdre on
a le bénéfice de cette espèce de dignité
ostentatoire en disant on vote tout de
suite comme ça on verra donc voilà c'est
de la politique au meilleur change du
terme mélange de
l'accusé j'ai nommé la politique
culturelle du gouvernement la
réalisatrice française Justine Trier a
remporté la Palme d'Or à Cannes pour son
film anatomie d'une chute et puis et
puis la prononcé ces mots qui ont
enflammé la classe politique écoutez
cette année le pays a été traversé par
une contestation historique extrêmement
puissante unanime de la réforme des
retraites
cette contestation a été liée et
réprimer de façon choquante et ce schéma
de pouvoir dominateur de plus en plus
décomplexé éclate dans plusieurs
domaines évidemment socialement c'est là
où c'est le plus choquant mais on peut
aussi voir ça dans toutes les autres
sphères de la société et le cinéma n'y
échappe pas
la marchandisation de la culture que le
gouvernement néolibéral défend est en
train de casser l'exception culturelle
française
dans la foulée la ministre de la Culture
a tweeté la chose suivante heureuse de
voir la Palme d'Or décerner à Justine
trier mais estomacé par son discours si
injuste ce film n'aurait pu voir le jour
sans notre modèle français de
financement du cinéma qui permet une
diversité unique au monde ne l'oublions
pas vous êtes aussi estomacé
alors bien sûr on va nous dire c'est pas
le même sujet liberté d'expression elle
parle de réforme des retraites elle
parle pas du financement du cinéma mais
enfin c'est quand même un modèle c'est
un modèle global que le modèle français
dans lequel les artistes sont
spécialement bien traités je ne dis pas
qu'il ne faut pas le faire mais enfin
honnêtement il y a un petit côté foutage
de gueule alors c'est peut-être même
pire que ça c'est moi j'ai toujours été
frappé de ce que de très grands artistes
je dis pas que c'est son cas moi c'est
une artiste de très grands artistes
peuvent être complètement idiots quand
il s'agit de faire de l'analyse
politique ils ont une espèce de myopie
qui les amène à être à la fois
formidable sur les grandes choses et
particulièrement minable sur sur
l'analyse des de c'est franchement c'est
frappant après ça
des fonds Philippe aussi sur la planète
unanime alors qu'il y a eu un rejet
assez important de la réforme des
retraites c'est peu contestable
une approximation pour dire le moins
donc et puis cette espèce de de côté
d'honneur de leçon on vous donne un prix
et vous voulez immédiatement tout ça moi
me paraît assez Virginie
pire que le gouvernement navré choix
politique passer la question comme ça
parce qu'en matière de culture il y a
des choix politiques qui sont effectués
par les gouvernements successifs en
l'occurrence par ce gouvernement
non mais évidemment oui je alors déjà je
suis incapable de vous répondre de
manière très précise on va être très
clair je pense qu'il y a des arbitrages
évidemment mais ce qu'on voit au niveau
de la région et Laurent Wauquiez n'est
absolument pas comparable je pense que
des choix de petits cultures comme on a
vu dans les villes françaises dans les
années 90 effectivement orange Marignane
ce qu'on voit dans la région Auvergne
Rhône-Alpes c'est pas du tout comparable
on peut pas on peut pas accuser le
gouvernement néolibéral de non c'est pas
vrai il y a une politique l'exception
culturelle elle a été théorisée elle ce
sont des chiffres et une industrie qu'on
fait vivre on a un rayonnement
international d'ailleurs il manque un
petit passage parce qu'elle dit quand
même merci pour cette exception parce
que j'en suis issu c'est grâce à ça que
je suis là devant vous manquait un petit
bout dans le discours donc non il y a
des je crois pas qu'on puisse dire comme
ça de manière aussi brutale que le
néolibéralisme aujourd'hui fait que le
modèle est totalement en danger c'est
pas vrai là-dessus sur cette accusation
portée contre le gouvernement la
première chose que je voudrais dire
c'est que je trouve normal que les
artistes donnent leur point de vue on
peut le partager moi je partage pas le
point de vue du bec pour vous le dire
franchement mais les deux artistes ont
le droit de s'exprimer et elle le fait
et c'est pas la première dans le cinéma
les plusieurs chaînes de radio avait
repris les interventions de Truffaut et
de Godard en mai 68 quand ils ont réussi
à faire annuler le canne à l'époque
c'était plus radical que ça encore un
bon et ça fait partie parce qu'ils ont
envie de dire et pourquoi pas ça partie
du débat public il n'y a pas de raison
qu'il ne s'exprime pas les artistes donc
ça ne me gêne pas au contraire plus je
suis plutôt d'accord avec elle le
terminal mise à part mais je suis plutôt
d'accord avec elle sur cette sur ce
qu'elle a dit après comme vous je pense
que le
ce qu'elle a dit est plus large enfin
elle a dit des choses après et en effet
elle a reconnu qu'elle venait de
l'exception culturelle française et que
c'est pour ça qu'elle avait pu faire ce
film donc c'était pas non plus un déni
de réalité bon alors après moi je
connais pas suffisamment ce que fait le
gouvernement d'aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il y a toujours un risque de
d'application une politique néolibérale
dans la culture je suis pas sûr qu'en
effet ce soit aussi radical que ce que
fait leur invoquer je l'espère en tout
cas du point de vue du gouvernement mais
franchement je suis pas le mieux à même
pour vous donner un avis
justement avoir Laurent qu'est-ce qu'il
a déclaré dans un entretien accordé au
JDD la semaine dernière donc le
président de la Région Auvergne
Rhône-Alpes déclare le ministère de la
Culture est devenu un guichet une
machine à faire tourner les subventions
qu'une petite poignée de personnes
considère comme un Dieu dans notre pays
la majorité des crédits du ministère de
la Culture sont réservés à Paris à la
région
Île-de-France et à quelques métropoles
on a construit une culture à deux
vitesses il y a une politique culturelle
de gauche une politique culturelle de
droite Juliette là actuellement le
gouvernement mène une politique
culturelle qui est tout sauf néolibéral
c'est une politique culturelle qui a vu
augmenter le budget de la culture avec
la ministre de la culture actuelle de
plus de 7%. on a le CNC qui continue à
financer des films qui fait que le
cinéma français est le premier cinéma du
monde aujourd'hui par ces productions
donc on peut pas dire aujourd'hui
le nombre de films produits par le
nombre de films produits donc on ne peut
pas dire d'accord mais on peut pas dire
aujourd'hui que on a une politique
néolibérale donc ça c'est le premier
point après le second point qui est de
savoir est-ce qu'on flèche nos crédits
en fonction de la ligne politique des
films nationalement non on est
heureusement enfin le CNC fait son
travail comme depuis plus mais alors il
y a des sortes de petite élite
privilégiés et puis tous les autres donc
il dit il dit que on flèche nos crédits
c'est-à-dire qu'on octroie nos crédits
en fonction de la couleur politique des
des films produits mais non bien sûr que
c'est faux mais en revanche il se
projette parce que lui c'est exactement
ce qu'il fait dans sa région si ce n'est
que lui ne le fait pas en fonction de la
couleur politique mais en fonction de ce
qui le soutiennent ou qui ne le
soutiennent pas c'est à dire que c'est
carrément une privatisation la politique
culturelle qui est menée et ça n'est
évidemment pas le cas de ce qui menait
au niveau et à l'échelle de l'État
Philippe là-dessus sur cette culture à
deux vitesses dont parle c'est
franchement assez faux quand vous voyez
le le festival qui sont subventionnés
largement ce que je trouve d'ailleurs
très bien dans toute la France enfin
l'idée que les subventions aillent
exclusivement à Paris à l'Île-de-France
et à certaines grandes villes oui en
masse et les Yvon parce que c'est là
qu'il y a le plus de monde mais c'est
pas vrai que c'est réservé à ces villes
là en revanche là où je pense que
Laurent Wauquiez a pas complètement tort
c'est avec le système de distribution
des aides je crois pas qu'ils soient
biaisé je suis d'accord avec Juliette
pour des raisons politiques quelque
chose aujourd'hui
en revanche le non le point qui me
semble vraiment important qu'il suggère
qu'il ne dit pas explicitement mais qui
mériterait vraiment un travail c'est que
vous avez beaucoup de ces guichets parce
que c'est vrai il y a des guichets c'est
normal c'est ce qu'il s'agit de
distribuer subventions pourquoi il y
aurait pas de guichet sont tenus par des
espèces de jury ou par des commissions
qui sont assez endogames et qui sont
souvent assez proches des artistes qui
reçoivent c'est un peu inévitable à
certains égards puisque c'est un
écosystème mais je pense qu'il y a
probablement des efforts à faire pour
qu'il y ait un peu moins de
réprobabilité sous l'angle de
l'endogamie et j'allais dire pour être
honnête et directe d'une épotisme dans
certains cas donc ça il y a certaines
lois d'améliorations à faire on parle
beaucoup de walkies mais de cancel
culture on a l'impression
personnellement que que c'est la culture
devient un enjeu politique j'ai tort de
plus en plus un enjeu politique dans le
débat public aujourd'hui Virginie non
bien je sais pas s'il y a quelque chose
de nouveau en revanche
après
non moi ce qui me semble nouveau c'est
la c'est la radicalité revient dans la
dans le monde de la culture ça c'est
vrai effectivement on a vu Adèle Haenel
on a vu tous ces débats et c'est quelque
chose qu'on avait oublié vous avez vous
avez cité effectivement ces années là
même Tavernier piala moi je vous savez
les artistes qui refusent leur prix
petite je regardais ça c'est pas nouveau
mais là ça revient parce que c'est vrai
que depuis on a toujours eu les
intermittents qui il y avait plein de
débats qui seraient invités mais là il y
a une forme de radicalité je trouve
vraiment avec Adèle notamment
euh qui qui est dans la société
française dans la politique ils se
retrouvent un peu effectivement dans le
débat suspendu merci président l'archet
comme chaque semaine on termine cette
émission par un top flop une question
simple qui a marqué l'actualité de la
semaine en bien ou en mal cher Philippe
vous commencez qui est votre top de la
semaine le top de la semaine c'est les
Français parce que j'ai vu un sondage
qui disait que 71 % je crois des
Français enfin un nombre très élevé
considéré qu'il fallait lutter contre la
hausse la dérive de la dette publique
alors je trouve que c'est une prise de
conscience qui honore les Français je
signale simplement enfin je rappelle
j'imagine tout le monde le sait que en
2024 est assez peu probable que 2024
soit une année d'excédent budgétaire ce
sera la cinquantième année de suite de
déficit budgétaire on vous invitera pour
l'occasion votre flop Philippe a le flop
j'ai trouvé que c'était facile cette
semaine c'est Didier Raoul alors enfin
maintenant avec cette cette descente à
l'ihau et c'est cette perquisition enfin
qui qui
le soupçon est grave ça serait de
d'avoir triché sur des sur des études
quand même qui visait approuver quelque
chose depuis le début moi je pense que
cette histoire de de d'assurance tourix
qui qui veut faire croire que la vérité
scientifique la seule c'est la sienne
ces problématiques là maintenant on
commence à voir qu'il y a un vrai sujet
plus que entre top mon top c'est le
discours de Bratislava d'Emmanuel Macron
je l'ai trouvé très bon surtout parce
que il a fait il a un peu fait un
exercice voilà d'autocritique sur
l'arrogance française ces discours avec
Poutine en arrière fond en appelant un
grand sursaut de l'Union européenne moi
j'ai été assez sensible le flop c'est
kering on parlait de froide fiscal le
groupe de luxe effectivement il y a un
article dans Le Monde cette semaine qui
explique comment avec des filiales of
Shore et rémunérer leurs cadres en
évitant de payer leurs impôts Christophe
votre top de la semaine qu'est-ce que
c'est mon top c'est la deuxième
conférence internationale qui se tient à
Paris en ce moment à l'Unesco sous
l'égide de l'ONU sur la limitation et si
on peut l'arrêt de la production de
plastique parce que c'est un des
questions environnementales les plus
importantes avec le changement de climat
une biodiversité donc c'est très bien
que ça se tienne on est loin
malheureusement d'avoir un accord mais
en tout cas la dynamique internationale
est lancée c'est très positif et votre
flop et mon flop ce sera toujours sur
les questions environnementales totales
qui après l'assemblée générale qui s'est
tenue de du groupe des actionnaires
récemment et maintenant devant la
justice sur une question toute simple
est-ce qu'il faut que les
investissements soient d'abord consacrés
aux hydrocarbures ce qu'ils continuent à
faire y compris en Ouganda dans des
projets extrêmement controversés il
l'avait fait en Sibérie également ou
est-ce qu'il faut au contraire qu'il
privilégie les énergies renouvelables et
on en est loin Juliette votre top de la
semaine alors mon top c'est un peu un
flop en réalité c'est le tiers des
enseignants dans un dernier sondage qui
ne trouve plus de sens à leur mission
mais ça n'est pas de leur faute il y a
une dévalorisation de la fonction
d'enseignant depuis la fin des trentes
glorieuses et le rôle précisément de
l'État et de la société c'est de les
revaloriser l'une des pistes il y a pas
que l'augmentation des salaires l'une
des pistes pourrait être de leur donner
accès par un concours au moment où il
rentre dans la fonction publique à tous
tous les autres métiers de la sur votre
deuxième flop et le deuxième flop
c'était lasse le la petite ligne c'est
qui s'est suicidé au terme d'un
harcèlement scolaire qui certes certes
n'a pas été détecté suffisamment tôt
mais au-delà de la responsabilité qui
est pointée des institutions et
d'ailleurs le ministre de l'éducation
nationale assez courageusement a dit que
ça avait été une faillite il y a la
responsabilité aussi globalement des
parents des enfants harceleurs et moi je
crois qu'il faut réintroduire un sens de
la responsabilité et de l'éducation à
l'autre à la bienveillance bref faut que
les parents fassent leur job merci
beaucoup c'est la fin de cette émission
merci à tous les cas d'avoir participé
un grand salut à vous derrière votre
écran on me dit dans l'oreillette que
vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux à
nous suivre merci à vous vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission en replay sur
notre nouvelle plateforme public
sénat.fr on se retrouve quant à nous la
semaine prochaine même jour même heure
et même endroit bye bye
[Musique]